on commence enfin à en parler new start
dernier traité majeur sur le contrôle
des armements encore en vigueur entre
les etats-unis et la russie expire dans
moins d'un an désormais et si le texte
est reconductible sur cinq ans une
possibilité que moscou voit d'un bon
oeil
washington n'y a toujours pas répondu
favorablement
nous sommes préoccupés par le manque de
certitudes concernant le traité new
start la prolongation du traité est une
sage décision qui permettrait de
maintenir une situation stratégique
équilibré d'éviter la destruction
complète des mécanismes de contrôle des
missiles nucléaires et nous ferait
gagner un peu de temps pour discuter des
méthodes de contrôle des nouveaux
armements et des nouvelles technologies
compte tenu de toutes ces questions le
président russe a proposé que les états
unis prolongent le traité new start sans
autres conditions
nous attendons toujours une réponse il
n'est donc pas trop tôt pour entamer les
négociations car celle ci risque d'être
longue et fastidieuse
dans un premier temps la question de
savoir quels pays vont y participer
la russie souhaite conclure un accord
sur la maîtrise des armements et le
nucléaire c'est intelligent et nous
aussi nous pensons que ce serait une
bonne chose et nous y joindre ont aussi
certainement comme vous le savez la
chine
nous pouvons les faire venir plus tard
où nous pouvons les faire venir
maintenant au passage le président
américain verrait d'un bon oeil le fait
de se servir d'une rencontre entre pays
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité pour discuter du sujet quoi
qu'il en soit les autorités américaines
ont déjà une idée sur le contenu du
prochain texte
en effet le département d'état évalue la
possibilité d'étendre le champ
d'application de l'actuelle new start a
d'autres armes russes lesquels sont pour
la plupart encore au stade du
développement
nous devons donc nous assurer que le
nouveau texte couvre non seulement ce
qui est actuellement couverte par new
start mais aussi la gamme de nouveaux
systèmes russes en cours de
développement qui ne sont pas et ne
seraient pas inclus dans new start comme
ces nouveaux systèmes légèrement
exotiques tels que le drones sous-marins
à propulsion nucléaire appelé poséidon
les missiles de croisière à propulsion
nucléaire les missiles balistiques
air-sol une disposition nouvelle qui
n'est pas pour plaire franchement à
moscou la déclaration du département
d'état pour autant que je puisse en
juger énumère toutes les nouvelles armes
russes y compris celles en cours
d'élaboration et celles qui ne sont pas
en service et ses restrictions qui
s'appliquent à la recherche et des vols
demain on court mais non achevées
qu'elle soit russo américaines sont en
principe exclus et ne font pas l'objet
de discussions ni maintenant ni à
l'avenir étant donné le niveau de
défiance qui existent entre les deux
pays
il faut que ces discussions soient les
plus fréquentes et franche possible si
on veut parvenir à des progrès et ce
pour éviter de se retrouver sans aucun
traité limitant la prolifération de
missiles
dès le mois de février prochain et c'est
déjà dans moins d'un an